is it Sakamoto or Sakamoto the English
voice actors of persona 5 went with some
unorthodox pronunciations for the games
Japanese names and places we made this
comparison videos so you can decide if
the English voice actors did the game
justice or if they fell short if you got
persona 5 on ps4 and you disliked the
English audio you're in luck as you can
get the Japanese audio DLC for free note
if you want to switch the languages in
the middle of a playthrough you cannot
change it in the config menu you have to
toggle it in the loading menu by
pressing triangle if you enjoyed this
persona 5 video give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to our channel while you're
there check out our history of persona
video which can make you a persona
trivia expert in less than 30 minutes
whatever your language preference is let
us know in the discussion below thanks
for watching yes deepest goodnight
oh good idea even then you get it I bet
you get to a call today guys just
o'clock
[Music]
go go go - I see my Miata
Nikita again okay good now get running
this is our only chance stay calm you
can get away now we'll retrieve the
briefcase on our it was that don't worry
about it
just concentrate on getting away Nana
[Music]
mother wakaranai Dogra mood Anand a
tsunami nada
soretomo Oh Jojo muy muy ah ah
chimera naginata no Sokka Casca hedonic
stairs turn over
tsukumo Deepika Jamaica
okay get a warrior demo say by Hatake de
nada
Ivana kohaku milk song Koki Jimmy she
was on TOEIC or OSI model
Fuko stop
hora de Geer tishanna corner gage Tora
Shamu Zubin Thomas order Donna hey no
dozing off
you still don't get it do you
give it off come on
cooperate what you want another shot huh
what about the camera are you thinking
it can be used as video evidence so
you're not that dumb which is good as we
get to take as much time as we need
destruction of justice blackmail
defamation possession of weapons
[Music]
manslaughter - yeah talk about the works
the thing that all those crimes were led
by a punk like this and you seem to be
enjoying every second of it from now is
Chico Chico Noemi Renata siakam arma de
attendez Oh see me go go hey okay need
arrow ghana yeah yoni midoriko tony
samastah me not okey no estaba con ojos
de Baca tates horrible a no second Ito's
como Tito Sika Sika tannins sharona's
see tato minguk okay nara moto shiranai
hito ni yo mas todos real co hartomo
tans
meso Arianna MoDOT a Miskin alto da
Stowe real koto Cara arena osoto hey
Esteban daya yoko gbendeck is Gitana
okay so Tasya mata a coach EO yada unity
demo not viv you it's such a delight to
enjoy coffee of this quality you could
stay until you find a place you know I
can't promise it it'd be comfortable
here though thank you but I'll return to
the dorms I realized something after
talking with everyone last night perhaps
it's due to my upbringing but I don't
know anything of the world let alone
other people if I'm to depict people in
my art I need to learn more about them I
must interact with them more I'll return
to the doors and start over by talking
with the people closest to me
I see good on you for realizing that
yourself there's no need to exaggerate
may I come again sometime to enjoy a
coffee my doors are always open hey
cotton on agua con aeronauts Kokomo
sodas
una Casa Archie soy una nota so Chico
sadani close to gotcha
Amitabha Syria tomba khamoshi das es any
nannies
[Music]
Wow Sokka so you got Anna camasta Tanaka
i'ma nah
[Music]
Sakamoto neocon Cano Cano yarrow gerado
Nana circus Tara ooh Madonn Arikara na
surrett Nani anyway what's with you like
how you relate the other day was a
Lionel
where's that weird rumor about you -
what do you want with him
right back at you
you're not even in our class but we just
happen to get to know each other what
are you planning on doing to mr. kuhmo
cheetah huh I see i getcha
[Music]
you're all buddy-buddy with come Ishita
after all this has nothing to do with
you Sakamoto if you found out what he's
been doing behind your back
you dumped him right away behind my back
what's that supposed to mean
[Music]